الى شخصيه الاسبوع في صباح العربيه
واخترنا هذا الاسبوع جعفر جاكسون الذي
اختير ليجسد دور عمي ملك البوب مايكل
جاكسون خبر اختيار جعفر انتشر عبر العالم
وربما ما زاده انتشارا وما كشفته شركه
الانتاج لاينس
سيتناول جميع جوانب حياه ملك البوب بما في
ذلك مزاعم الاعتداء الجنسي على الاطفال
حياه مايكل جاكسون مليئه بالدراما وانتهت
هذه الدراما بوفاه الفنان عام 2009 بسبب
سكته قلبيه يقال ان سببها هو كوكتيل من
المهدئات بحسب تقارير بالعوده الى جعفر
وبالتاكيد سعيد بهذه الفرصه فمباشره نشر
صوره لنفسه وهو يقوم بتقليد مايكل جاكسون
امام المراه
والدته مايكل جاكسون ايضا كاترين جاكسون
قالت انها سعيده بان يلعب حفيدها دور بنها
الراحل على الشاشه سنتعرف اليوم على هذه
الشخصيه
[موسيقى]
جعفر جاكسون هو ابن شقيق مايكل جاكسون وهو
ثاني اصغر ابناء شقيق مايكل جيرمن جاكسون
وهو مغني وكاتب اغاني ستكون هذه هي المره
الاولى التي يصور فيها الشاب البالغ من
العمر 26 عاما فيلما كبيرا كان جعفر يغني
ويرقص منذ ان كان في الثانيه عشره من عمره
وقد اظهر موهبته من خلال اعمال لفنانين
مثل سام كويك وميرفين بالاضافه الى اغانيه
الاصليه والده جيرمان جاكسون هو مغني
امريكي حائز على جائزه رامي وعضو فرقه
جاكسون 5 كان جيرمن الاخ الاقرب لمايكل
جاكسون تعرف على الاسلام اثناء زياره له
الى البحرين ثم اعتنق الاسلام واختار اسم
محمد عبد العزيز اسما له لكن اسم جيرمن
بقى هو الاشهر عالميا
[موسيقى]